حارس الازدهار هو اسم التحالف الدولي
الجديد لمواجهه الحوثيين بقياده امريكا
وواشنطن تضم دوله عربيه للوساطه مع
اليمنيين صحف عبريه تصرح تدمير الفصائل
قريبا سيكون وهما بكتيريا قاتله تفتك
بجنود عبريين خلال معارك القطاع الفصائل
تسخر من عثور جيش تلبيب على احد انفاقها
الكيان ينفذ عمليه العصفور المفترس على
منشات ايرانيه الجيش العبري يضع خططه
للهجوم على لبنان صواريخ كيم جونغ تهدد
جميع انحاء الولايات المتحده وبوتين يوجه
رساله مطمئنه للناتو المانيا تعترف شن
برلين حرب على موسكو تعني ان الالمان
يشنون حربا على انفسهم الاتحاد الاوروبي
يضع الحزمه 12 من العقوبات ضد روسيا
وتراشق داخلي بالاتهامات في
اوكرانيا تحالف ضد
اليمن تحالف جديد تسعى الولايات المتحده
لانشائه لضرب اليمن بعد تصعيد الحوثيين
لهجمات في البحر الاحمر هنا وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستون يصل الى تل ابيب في
زياره اعلن خلالها عن قوه التشكيل لحمايه
بحريه جديده تحت مسمى حارس الازدهار وسط
الهجمات المتكرره التي شنها الحوثيون على
السفن التجاريه التي تعبر البحر الاحمر
للعمل على ضمان ان يصبح البحر الاحمر امنا
للشحن حسب ما ذكرت صحيفه الجارديان
بريطانيه على ذات السياق كشفت مصادر
لوكاله بلومبرج الامريكيه ان البيت الابيض
يتواصل مع الحوثيين عبر سلطنه عمان وبعض
الوسطاء الاخرين لحثهم على وقف الهجمات
على السفن في البحر الاحمر فيما اعلنت
شركه الشحن البحري اورنيت اوفر سيز
كونتينر لاين او او سي ال عن وقفها الفوري
لشحن البضائع العبريه بكافه انواعها وفي
كافه الوجهات سواء كانت للتصدير او
الاستيراد وياتي بيان الشركه على وقع
تهديدات الحوثيين بمنع كافه السفن المتجهه
الى تلبيب عن طريق باب المندب الذي يسيطر
عليه اليمن هنا كانت القوات البحريه
للحوثيين قد اعلنت تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه
نوعيه ضد سفينتين لهم ارتباط بالكيان
العبري الاولى سفينه سوان اتلانتيك محمله
بالنفط والاخرى سفينه ام اس سي كلارا تحمل
حاويات وقد تم استهدافهما بصاروخين بحريين
مناسبين واشار البيان الى ان استهداف
السفينتين جاء بعد رفض طاقمه ما الاستجابه
لنداءات القوات البحريه اليمنيه وها هو
المصدر يتحدث الحوثيون يكثفون من هجماتهم
في البحر الاحمر اخرها استهداف السفينه
سوان اتلانتك النرويجيه وتبنيهم حتى هذه
اللحظه انهم من قاموا بهذه العمليه هذ
الداخل العبري يعلنها بصراحه وعلى لسان
صحيفه يودي عوت احران التي اكدت ان اي
اعلان عن تدمير الفصائل قريبا سيكون وهما
ومفصلا عن الواقع واليكم
المصدر كشفت صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت ان اي
اعلان عن تدمير حماس قريبا سيكون وهما
ومفصلا عن الواقع ها هي الفصائل تسخر من
الجيش العبري حين نشر اعلامها العسكري
مقطع فيديو تحت عنوان وصلتم متاخرين
المهمه انجزت وذلك عقب اعلان الجيش العبري
العثور على نفق ضخم قريب من من معبر ايراز
من جانبها قالت هيومان رايتس واتش ان
الحكومه العبريه تستخدم تجويع المدنيين
اسلوبا للحرب في القطاع ما يشكل جريمه حرب
كما ان الجيش يعرقل عمدا المساعده
الانسانيه ليخرج الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب ويؤكد ان الوضع في الشرق
الاوسط خرج عن نطاق السيطره بسبب الاخطاء
الامريكيه ويهدد بالتحول الى كارثه في
معارك القطاع بكتيريا قاتله تفتك بجنود
عبريين حيث افادت هيئه البث العبريه ان
جنودا عبريين لقوا مصرعهم داخل المستشفيات
بسبب اصابتهم ببكتيريا قاتله وذلك خلال
علاجهم من اصابات اثناء القتال في القطاع
وها نحن نتصفح
[موسيقى]
المصدر من جانب اخر قال وزير الدفاع
بريطانيا السابق بين والاس في مقاله
لصحيفه تيليغراف ان تكتيكات رئيس وزراء
تلبيب النتنياهو ستغذي الصراع الفلسطيني
العبري لمده 50 عاما اخرى واعرب الوزير
السابق عن اعتقاده بان تكتيكات النتنياهو
تعمل على اضعاف بلاده في جبهه اخرى قالت
اذاعه الجيش العبري ان مجموعه قرصنه عبريه
اعلنت تنفيذ هجوم سيبراني تسبب في تعطيل
منظومه امداد الوقود في ايران فيما ذكرت
موقع واينت ان مجموعه القرصنه تعرف نفسها
باسم العصفور المفترس على الحدود
اللبنانيه اعلنت مقاومه لبنان عن استهداف
منصتين للقبه الحديديه العبريه الشماليه
مستعمره كابري بسلاح المدفعيه فيما ذكرت
صحيفه التايمز في تقرير لها ان الجيش
العبر وضع خططا لشان عمليه بريه جديده في
الشمال ضد مقاومه لبنان الامر الذي يهدد
بتصعيد الصراع في الشرق الاوسط ولننتقل
الى الشرق الاسيوي حيث قال شينجو ماياكي
نائب وزير الدفاع البرلماني الياباني ان
الصاروخ البالستي العابر للقرات الذي
اطلقته كوريا الديمقراطيه بقي في حاله
طيران لمده 73 دقيقه كما انه يستطيع
الوصول لاي نقطه في الاراضي
الامريكيه بوتين يبدا
التهدئه بعد ان دب الخوف في العالم من
مواجهه بين النيتو وروسيا خرج الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ليؤكد ان روسيا
ليست لديها اي اهتمامات جيو سياسيه او
اقتصاديه او عسكريه للدخول في صراع ضد
النيتو بالمقابل وفي مقابله مع صحيفه
فرانكفورتر الماي تسايتونج الالمانيه صرحت
نائبه في مجلس النواب الالماني البوندستاج
سر فاجن كشت انه من خلال دعم العقوبات ضد
روسيا تشن المانيا حربا اقتصاديه ليس ضد
موسكو فقط بل ضد نفسها فيما صرح ضابط
المخابرات العسكريه الامريكيه السابق سكوت
ريتر بان الدول الغربيه قد تتخذ قرارا حول
التخلص من الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمير
زيلينسكي لانه بات غير ضروريا لنتصار ح
المصدر
[موسيقى]
امامكم هنا قالت صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز ان
بعض حلفاء اوكرانيا الاكثر نشاطا يبحثون
احتمال موافقه كياف على تجميد الصراع
وتقديم ذلك باعتباره انتصارا لاوكرانيا
بينما صرح وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرغي
لافروف انه اذا كانت الولايات المتحده
تريد الاستقرار خلف مياهها مثل بريطانيا
فعليها ان تعي ان هناك خطوط في العلاقات
مع موسكو لا يمكن تجاوزها خلال ذلك وافق
مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي على الحزمه الاث من
العقوبات ضد روسيا والتي التي تشمل قيودا
اقتصاديه وقائمه موسعه من العقوبات
الشخصيه ضد الافراد والمنظمات في اوكرانيا
اكد القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه فاليري زالو جيني انه تم
العثور على جهاز تنس في احد مكاتبه واوضح
زلوج ان هناك مكاتب عده يعمل فيها وتم
العثور على الخلل في واحد منها فيما نفى
سيرغي لوشي شينكو مستشار مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني صلتهم بجهاز التنس موضحا ان
زالو جيني هو من يسيطر على المبنى ميدانيا
قالت الدفاع الروسيه ان وحدا من قوات
الجنوب الروسيه صدت في اتجاه دونيسك
وباسناد من قوات المدفعيه وانظمه قذفات
اللهب الثقيله تسع هجمات للاليه 24 و28
الاليين و81 و79 المظليين الهجومي التابعه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه واضافت الوزاره
الروسيه ان قواتها دمرت مركز قياده اللواء
الاول للحرس الوطني الاوكراني في اراضي
جمهوريه دونيسك الشعبيه ضد طيران العمليه
التكتيكي والمسيرات والقوات الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه لتعلن هنا الدفاع الروسيه عن
الحصيله اليوميه بخساره ما يزيد عن 640
جنديا اوكرانيا في كل
الجبهات